Colorado has legalized recreational
marijuana have you as you've all heard
about people are smoking dope by crazy
they're let's look at people in line at
the loto Wellness Center it was pretty
cold it was pretty cold but that did not
stop these good citizens these potheads
from getting their weed not surprisingly
sales have been through the roof and
actually some of the stores are running
out of weed as we speak
we are currently out of recreational
cannabis please check back with us
tomorrow there have already been reports
that the prices of weed are going up
because the demand is so high obviously
you can already tell that I am
completely for recreational weed I think
it's completely fine and we're gonna
stop putting people in jail for no
reason and all kinds of stuff is this
just a big win for the for the weed gang
is the you know just that it got that it
happened already that we have some win
for this country I think yes we've been
wasting so much money taking so many
people putting them in prison because
they've estimates it's a 45 to 100
billion dollar industry if we were to
legalize it nationally which we should
do it's a lot safer than alcohol it
should be treated responsibly they
supporters have done a great job of
going state-by-state first 20 states
with medical marijuana privileges and
now two states Colorado and Washington
that are gonna allow recreational use
and I think it's long overdue and I
think it says well it needs to be
treated responsibly and I think it's a
huge improvement for this country so
we're not creating criminals out of
those who are not do you see this as
like a gay rights thing it's just going
to be one stay and then the next day and
the next I think that the propaganda
machine against marijuana recreational
or medical just was so strong for so
long and the wheels are just completely
falling off that I think there are
certain generations of people in certain
geographical locations of people that
were a little bit more weary of
marijuana and those maybe though maybe
those states rights those states will
never decide to legalize it but I do
think the more and more people that see
that look the world didn't end crime
didn't rise all these horrible things
didn't happen that the kind of anti weed
propaganda prohibition machine was going
when when they say Washington and
Colorado are doing just fine and the
state is making revenue from it and
people are happy and
people are actually getting care and
there's less people in their jails and
you see all these positives come out of
it as long as the information is given
to the right people then I think it will
go state by state but there are certain
people that do not want to hear it you
know I feel like my mother still thinks
that like marijuana is gonna make you
crazy and jump off a building and rob
people and stab or I didn't she just
yeah it's like those things from the 50s
she watched a lot of PSA the PSA is in
the 50s basically still run through her
head and the information that she still
watches in the internet sites she visits
in the news channels that she watched
and still have her believe that it is
still the 1950s oh look she and her
peers may never accept it but I think as
more more people do it's yeah it's over
you know I work in a bubble here
progressive place on The Young Turks
we're obviously pretty much everyone's
for this but I was watching Bill
O'Reilly last night and he was going on
and on about how you know this is gonna
ruin society and that the statistics
about the jail thing aren't correct he
believes that I don't think he does
believe it either I think he's just
saying it he can't he's nice stupid man
it was a very very smart person right
and I don't believe Bill O'Reilly can
truly believe that marijuana is gonna
ruin the fabric of our society so are
you saying he's doing it for ratings
just to play to the base of Fox News I
can't believe that you'd say he just
needs I think that there's been nothing
in the past you know a few days that's
gotten will get people riled up that he
could definitely play to the base and
say outrageous things about so that's
why he said that and so I do not think
that when he takes off his micro I think
when he takes up his microphone he's
like that's actually on this one yeah is
there any credence to that to the anti
weed people because I don't want to be I
don't want to be so flippant about it it
has been illegal I am obviously for it
but is there any credence to what they
say I mean we already have alcohol was
illegal and you know alcohol is actually
far worse than than marijuana but is
there anything can you think of anything
of course underage kids smoking
marijuana
whichever one it's a huge problem and it
needs to be there needs to be an
education program to go along with us
and moderation which works for marijuana
as well as alcohol needs to be
emphasized and and I think thorough
training of people and an explanation of
this is this is this something that does
make you high and it's got to be done
with caution but if we need to legalize
marijuana nationally and I've got a
I advocate of that forever the
Millennials are now coming into power
and they're gonna take this issue I
think nationally and I think you'll see
a national marijuana legalization push
going strongly we've had two great
heroes doing it for an answer that Peter
Soros said yeah or George Soros and
Peter Lewis who just passed away have
been putting up millions and millions of
dollars in these 20 states and in
Washington and Colorado and in other
countries too with the George Soros is
interest and I think it's important I
think that we need to do that create a
level playing field in this country so
it is the next step of this whole thing
is that someone's gonna we did a story
on a couple of weeks ago but that
someone's gonna step in and really make
a push to have like a Starbucks we yeah
it's not this isn't gonna happen through
you know I know the Millennials are
gonna push any people or gonna want it
but it's not gonna happen in like a
George Soros or someone who has really
really big you know potential you know
corporate vested things like farming
like a monsanto type something like that
who wants to really make profits tobacco
industry somebody like that a little
parcel you need to have a we die
obviously I think that's what gets
things done in America right now that's
probably what I think is one of the
biggest problems in America right now is
that something doesn't become acceptable
until some huge corporation finds a way
to make it profitable and that's fine
that they're allowed to do that it's
going to push it through but I think
that's just the truth of it is is that
if you want to see you know that
federally being okay for everyone to
have weed and to have it be acceptable
in every street you need a corporation
that middle America trusts starting to
endorse it to fund research on it that
starts to suspend it to a positive thing
then you'll see it everywhere and don't
forget when something's legalized then
the thrill is taken away I'm told in the
Netherlands that the only people buying
marijuana there which has been legal for
20 plus years are tourists the people
there now that it's not a novelty and I
predict in in collar in Washington when
the excitement dies down has just been a
week or so but you'll start to see the
sales slow down and people maybe coming
in from other states but I think they're
people adjust and and it's a good thing
yeah I totally agree final thought on
this you know I've all the mainstream
news on this every time they talk about
this do you notice the b-roll that they
show they show all these like colleagues
and big sweaters and hoodies hoodies are
very dangerous
Feeny and their beanies and hoodies and
they're never shaven and they're taking
bong hits like huge bong hits and
laughing like even the messaging that
the mainstream media is pushing not even
verbal is is bad on this right it's not
only bad it's lazy and it's childish
yeah but at least are showing faces the
floor was always blurred or bad so I
guess they're showing or they're showing
that it's just a thing of the youth it's
just something of slacker culture it's
just something of scary potential
criminal hoodie culture it's not
something that people that are genuinely
either thick or older or suffer from
anxiety or just feel like chilling out
the same way a person goes home and have
a glass of wine is doing so I think they
need to attach more the more the faces
of weed instead of reporting on that
it's but it's embarrassing to look at
the mandala it's childish it's lazy to
do that anytime they played it done
somebody references snoop with weed or
plays Bob Marley in the background I'm
like is that how narrow-minded you are
that you think that the only people that
have any interest in marijuana cultures
like are either Snoop Dogg or listening
to Bob Marley or are in college or can't
shave their face like grow up yeah